people here say it's like a tornado of
fire that swept away everything within
seconds
those who survived are trying to figure
out what happened as they assess the
i don't damage how it happened it was
like a whirlwind i helped the children
run i couldn't do anything because of
what was happening outside
you can see my house the garage is
destroyed i couldn't save anything it's
god's will thank god the children are
safe
forest fires have become an annual
occurrence in algeria where climate
change is turning large areas into a
tinder box
most of the deaths this time have
occurred in the el tarf region near the
eastern border with tunisia
where temperatures have reached 48
degrees celsius
hundreds of people have had to flee
their homes with many more having
suffered from burns or respiratory
issues as a result of the smoke
some are blaming arsonists
what do you gain when you set a fire and
people die what does the arsonist gain
from setting these fires i hope his
heart burns
across the country dozens of fires are
still burning with authorities concerned
strong winds and a blistering heat wave
could spark new flames
that they are ill-equipped to fight
chilean wolf al jazeera